c'est une expérience qui est totalement
différente même si c'est quand même une
expérience d'acteur et c'est un exercice
que j'aime bien même dans les films que
je fais de trouver la voix du personnage
voici les nouvelles recrues kevin tu
vois c'est le tout petit honorable ses
quotas j'ai cherché une voie qui n'est
pas la mienne parce que j'ai pas je ne
suis pas scarlett
mesdames messieurs est ce que l'un de
vous n'a jamais rêvé de travailler pour
le plus grand super méchant de tous les
temps enfin je sais pas si c'est une
liberté mais en tout cas un espace de
création qui est totalement différent de
celui des films je vais dire normaux
mais enfin oui des films en tout cas de
ce que je fais voilà particulièrement
sur celui là il ya c'est vraiment de la
comédie
il a une voix à trouver parce que parce
que personnage une espèce de puissance
diabolique comme ça est quelque chose
que j'ai jamais fait non coeur et puis
j'en avais toujours rêver en plus extra
vous est follement petit vachement
jeunes et seul mois il est par un peu un
peu cool quoi il est un peu comme ça il
laisse un peu traîné mes mots surtout ne
prenez pas mal mais je goûte et s est
maintenant torture les gars arrêtez
c'est vraiment pas professionnel